all right true Jordy here a response to
login poll or as he likes to call me the
moderator PewDiePie called me the ref
you know can we just get this straight
true Johnny subscribe if you're new
basically in Logans last video he blamed
me for [__] in the bed at the London
press conference why is this so
one-sided why did the moderator let JJ
talk for five minutes and 20 seconds
straight yes I timed it and why are we
not talking about the fight maybe
because you didn't say a [__] word me
the first time at the LA press
conference we couldn't shut your blog
nobody was waiting for questions at the
first press conference so why why did
you sit down like a good little boy and
we're four questions at this one maybe
it was cuz the crowd I did a little bit
intimidated me and I'm not even angry at
that I don't even [__] me blame you I
probably would have felt it a bit meself
but don't just point the finger at me
cuz you want a [__] show and then I
remembered holy asshat this dude's King
hates me I don't hate nothing him do you
not I mean it's not love it's not hate
it's just nothing Jenna me he's just a
youtuber oh yeah I got hungry
two-for-one video will get a lot I just
don't think the moderator of the press
conference the person who should be
neutral the person who should be neutral
he had one of his Powell in Shannon
Briggs moderate the last press
conference who is known to be T
important was already for use last time
but it's sorry for chaos I have someone
he knows do we have thing is I was
accused of being biased against ksi on
the last fight
do your research but the person who
should be the one driving the
conversation should be a Logan in Jake
Paul hater
by the way I don't actually hate Jay he
seemed like an alright guy above me
better the press coffee seems alright
but yeah I don't even hate you you were
just a dick in the past and I criticized
you for it and a story and he's the one
who actually reminded ksi to call Jake
and I out after his last fight cuz if
you guys remember ksi literally almost
forgot yeah he told me before the fight
he was gonna call someone else and a
sister reminder this isn't a conspiracy
against you login it's not everything
isn't about you Paula I'm just doing me
[__] job here as a [__] presenter
they're freaking boys brought any
moderated the last press a little oh
they put a massive I wrote in my head
good Sam moderate now for
how dumb do you think your audience
asked me they can recognize the only guy
that looks like this all right [__] me
give them some credit you're not gonna
find many handsome chisel tattooed
northern men like this on you should
trust me on that look although if you're
looking good look at you they're boys
they're freaking boys just see if I was
one of JJ's boys I'd be in the sidemen
and I'd be way too rich to give a [__]
about what you've said about as me okay
what we're pals but normal poles than
what you and [__] shot and brings on
I would know how much you're paying shun
to be one of your mates does up here
good he moderated the last press
conference case I had with Jo Weller and
he knew what he was doing there I didn't
know what I was doing I did a pretty
good job thanks very much it's a shame
that you're now trying to stop me from
commenting in the next fight even though
I did a good job unfortunate and he knew
what he was doing then he was able to
keep it going
he's even said it himself reacting to
the LA press conference Shannon's lost
it here he watches me
he's a subscriber don't forget to hit
the like button Pole love it Shannon's
lost it here like no no one can get in
wording like as the media you have to
tell people when it's data this is just
it's gone please please take your own
advice
dude Shannon Bailey asked a single
question in that press conference at
least I asked a few to Jake adeje before
you got roasted by Jay Jay children I
mean it was not my fault
all right maybe it wasn't my fault me
I'll take I'm not gonna make out like
it's all you and not me I'll take
somebody in for it I probably should
have tried to step in sooner but we all
make mistakes don't we Logan I'm just
hopeful I everyone can forgive me for
this please please take your own advice
you hypocritical douche asaurus rex if
you're one of my audience and you don't
know Disney Channel language it means he
thinks I'm a [__] I can't even ask all
right I listen to what you have to say
Paul now you're gonna listen to what I
have to say and I'm not gonna [__]
everyone in me only I'm perfect and
you're the bad guy because that's what
every [__] youtuber does I'm happy to
take responsibility for your [__] up
or let's have it right I want to give
you credit to start off with something
you'll become an incredibly skilled at
pay on your pit and yourself out to be
the victims so that we're not losing
this fight you're still gonna win at the
end of the day anyway and that shows
you're a smart lad you think about every
single outcome and I respect that but
still you can make a sigh out to be the
bad guy all you want ultimately you're
going in there to punch each other
square in the face potentially knock
each other out and give each other brain
damage whatever either of
you say nothing will compare to that
there's a fight [__] what each other
saying in my opinion it's it's all fair
at this point you call me a log in Pole
here now understand why you think that
because the first video that you are
seeing of me was me screaming about
something that you did and attacking my
first impression of you was you laughing
at a [__] dead body in a forest a
victim of suicide probably the worst
first impression you can have in human
[__] history yeah I probably went
[__] overboard
you probably misjudged me the way I've
probably misjudged you you think I'm
here to pick the bones I'm a [__]
another another bloke at the caucus that
was your career at that time just trying
to shove as many subscribers in the bag
as I can as everyone has the end of
Logan Paul's life party that wasn't what
I was [__] involved in I'm a [__]
sport youtuber I'm a podcaster and I
don't make videos I make a living off of
other people's demises I made that video
out of pure hurt because I have people
who look up to me and and message me
about feeling suicidal and I've actually
found someone the way you found someone
but I didn't react the way you did and
it brought memories back like I would
have done for a lot of people when you
put that video out and I wasn't just
speaking from me and my hair I was
speaking for everyone else who would
have felt that way about what you did
and I'm not bringing this up now to try
and gain off of you a profit offer you
but you've you've brought my previous
actions to make me out a lot I couldn't
and I'm not having it now according to
the organizers of the event you're
stopping me from commenting in this
event and I've built a career and trying
to be the sports caster of YouTube and
now you get to take that away from me
that's this is your revenge me for me
making that video about you you now get
to stop me doing something I would love
to do you've got your revenge Congrats I
hope it satisfies you hope it makes you
happy you say I learning from your
mistakes I hope you're genuinely made as
man to man I do hope you're because I
don't envy the year you've had in fact
I'll give you credit it probably would
have broke in most people so you must
have some strength in you to [__]
tolerate that because when everyone
comes for you the way they came for you
it couldn't have been easy for you but
you called me a hypocrite as someone
affected by suicide how am I supposed to
forgive Logan for what he did when he
can't forgive me for having a problem
with what he did who's the [__]
hypocrite